one big item that was unexpected as of
two weeks ago today because I got a
phone call from someone that I trust
immensely and I was told hey you know
what is eco Elliot you better poke
around on this he's telling people that
he is planning to loan out from you
texted me right you texted me because
because let's give folks the history
here we've been saying all offseason he
needs to hold out and he's done nothing
before holding out to indicate that he
was willing to do that so that's when
this all started to become a little bit
real and I started to follow and I
started to poke around and lo and behold
when last Thursday came and went he was
not with the team when they flew from
Dallas to Oxnard California for training
camp Friday he did not show up the
holdout is now real and who knows when
this is going to end but Elliott using
the tool that's available and here's the
thing and I don't want to hear while
he's violating his contract he has a
contract folks there are two contracts
that apply to every player the contract
the player signs with his team and the
contract between the NFL and the NFL
Players Association and that broader
agreement gives every player the power
to hold out because the only
consequences he can be fined and if you
accept the fact that you can be fine and
for Elliott it's $40,000 a day if he's
willing to incur that responsibility
financially he has the power to hold out
every player under contract has the
power to hold out because there's
nothing in the labor deal that says they
can force you to show up where they can
shut you down for the full year if
you're not there when camp opens right
so he has the right to hold out he's
doing it he's exerting financial
pressure on the team this is a one-man
strike plain and simple and we'll see
how long he stays away to get what he
believes he deserves what he does
deserve from the Dallas Cowboys yep he
does deserve he deserves to be the
highest-paid running back in football
that's what he does deserve so I don't
think there's any doubt about that I'm
glad to see that he is taking this
action I mean of course we know Mike we
talk about it all the time running back
the most physically demanding position
and all of professional sports
there's just nothing worse than that I
mean I used to sit back there and hand
the
all off to Mike Alstott and Cadillac
Williams and see some of the collisions
and just go oh my gosh I don't know I
think I would have broke my neck seven
times on that one play how are they
getting up and walking back to the
huddle and acting like everything's fine
it's a brutal position
Ezequiel Eliot's plated about as good as
you can play they work him to death the
team is orchestrated around the run game
and him running the ball and his special
talents and his ability to move the pile
when nothing's there and do all that and
at the very base Hey
I mean Ezekiel Ali it's the tenth
highest-paid running back in football
barely making more money than guys like
Duke Johnson not making as much money as
Lamar Miller Leonard fournette Jarek
mckennon McKinnon excuse me Devonta
Freeman I mean all of those guys just
alone
have no business even being close to was
echolalia right there so come on Zeke
stand in there hold your ground and the
Cowboys got to pay you yeah I mean the
problem is the way the rookie wage scale
is set up and given the nature of the
running back position teams will get the
best years of a player before they have
to pay the player and if you can kick
the can if you can run out the clock you
can get to the point where you've gotten
everything that you possibly can you've
gotten great return on the dollars
you've invested and then you just go
find someone else and look Elliott needs
to take that possibility seriously
because Chris what did they do with
DeMarco Murray who in 2014 Yeah right he
led the league in rushing he set a
franchise single-season record that
still stands despite Elliott's time with
the team they said to DeMarco Murray
thanks for everything see you later and
he had to go signed with the
Philadelphia Eagles to get paid that's
what Elliott is trying to avoid and if
he doesn't take a stand they wait until
next year then maybe next year they
decide to wait until after he finishes
his fifth season then maybe they apply
the franchise tag for a year but at some
point you're running the risk of them
saying see you later
he's taking the stand now so he can get
maximum return for himself at a time
when he is giving maximum output to the
Dallas Cowboys and Steven Jones told me
back in May
he's the straw that stirs our drink
right that was back when that was back
when they they didn't think he was gonna
hold out yeah but
that has an impact now is the time to
get yourself paid otherwise it may never
happen
305 carries seventy seven receptions I
mean and you know again this this should
be the the new thing I mean every NFL
running back who you know is towards the
top of the league or a proven commodity
three years in you hold out immediately
until the NFL can find some other way to
fairly compensate these guys to go
against like what you said where you
know oh they're awesome players for four
or five years and now it's time for them
finally to get some new money but their
bodies beat the crap and now they get
low-balled by teams and don't get paid
because they go ball with you got abused
for four or five years there so I really
expect this to be a new thing within the
NFL as far as especially at the running
back position and I think Ezekiel it has
a lot of leverage in this situation
there's no proven commodity at running
back really for the Dallas Cowboys and
certainly nobody has talent that is
Ezekiel Elliott alright so how does this
play out there's a belief out there the
Cowboys will blink we know what happened
in 1993 Emmitt Smith skipped two regular
season games the Cowboys lost both of
them the Cowboys blinked then and it
worked out Cowboys went on to win the
Super Bowl no team had ever at that
point been oh and two and won the Super
Bowl Emmitt Smith returning went a long
way toward making that happen and he had
three seasons in at the time just like
Ezekiel Elliott now so I feel like at
some point the Cowboys are gonna give
this guy what he wants they're gonna
have no choice but to give him what he
wants I would think so right I mean
they're gonna have to go that way there
in the Superbowl window right now the
Dallas Cowboy team is ready to win the
Superbowl or at least go to it you look
at the roster on paper and I know it's
on paper but it's one of the best most
well put together football teams in the
whole league so yes this is this is like
you said the stir the straw that's
stirring the drink and this is a team
that's ready to win right now and I
would think the Jones family realizes
that and they make him the richest
running back in the NFL and and one-up
Todd Gurley in his contract by how much
I don't know but I would think anything
north of Todd Girly's contracts gonna
make as echolalia pretty happy now
the problem for the Cowboys as they they
have other guys who are
for contracts sooner than Elliot because
Elliot was a first-round pick they have
him for five years dak Prescott was not
a first rounder this is the final year
of his rookie contract Amari Cooper was
a first rounder in Oakland this is now
your five for him with dak Prescott and
he said Saturday it'll happen when it
happens he's trying not to be distracted
by it look I feel like that Prescott's
driving a hard bargain with the Cowboys
the Cowboys continue to put value on
being the starting quarterback of the
Dallas Cowboys but I don't get the
impression that Prescott and his
representatives are biting on that they
want to get paid and they look at what
he's done what he's capable of doing
they look at what other guys are being
paid and they're holding firm Chris and
I feel like if Prescott has to go
forward with two million dollars in
salary this year the other money that he
makes as a product endorser and the
promise of the franchise tag next year
or a long-term deal I think Prescott is
content to wait yeah I mean it seems
like he's not panicked about it either
way now I would think that Ezekiel
Elliott because he's holding out of
course has been moved to the top of the
list they're gonna try to get that done
and then I think dak Prescott is the
next guy on the list and I you know I
don't put it out of the realm of
possibility that yeah this doesn't
happen in training camp but maybe it
happens week five week six during the
season when they see okay we got things
settled as far as the salary cap
situation dak Prescott playing pretty
good looks like things are all in the
right direction but you know again he
shouldn't take a huge discount just
because he's a huge product endorser
anything like that he wants to be paid
fairly for market value and market value
is he's a tude he's a two-time playoff
quarterback in his three-year career and
he is another I'm not gonna say he's
Ezekiel Elliott important to that
offense but he is important and it's not
easy to play quarterback for that Dallas
Cowboy offense in the way they play and
he'd bring some special attributes and
has a little bit of a leadership factor
I think just like a Baker Mayfield who
we've talked about earlier in the show
to where you know he is that guy that
can lead the offense and be the leader
of a football team so I think it gets
done with Prescott just maybe not
sometime here in the near future do you
see him as a thirty million dollar a
year guy yeah I do I do I mean yes for
the current state of the quarterback
position right now I mean yes I mean if
Jimmy Garoppolo is a twenty seven and a
half
million dollar a year guy then damn dak
Prescott is a 30 million dollar a year
guy and people freak out when they hear
those numbers but but remember the sport
supports that yeah money is there the
salary cap is 188 million dollars per
team I remember when they started with
the salary cap back in 1993 1994 was
like 35 40 million per team you've got
guys making that much now individually
in Russell Wilson at 35 million so yeah
I think that the cowboys they're gonna
have to pay they're gonna have to pay
Eliot they're gonna have to pay Prescott
and then they're gonna have to ask
themselves right do we pay Amari Cooper
now Cooper's gonna make over 13 million
this year because he's in the option
year of his of his first-round contract
but yeah he's looking at 13 million plus
this year they franchise tag him next
year I mean they have to keep him around
they gave a first-round pick to get him
I know half of the season they they they
can't they can't just move on from him
after one full year after they gave up a
first round or so at some point he's
getting paid to Chris I would think so I
mean he does have the leverage on the
situation with what you're saying but
the way he performed at the end of the
year and the assets they gave a way to
get Amari Cooper but I think he is at
least a little less leverage than
Ezekiel Elliott and dak Prescott as far
as just asking for a huge guaranteed
lump sum and a big contract just at
least at this point just because you
know there was that little blip on the
map in 2017 where yeah it was not a good
season for Amari Cooper and the first
six games of the year last year but the
Oakland Raiders were not very good
either so you know I think he's
realistic in knowing he needs to put a
few more games or good games on film
before he can start commanding big big
time dollars and I think the Dallas
Cowboys would probably want to see that
too before they're really willing to
commit you know Odell Beckham jr. or
what maybe Michael Thomas type money at
the wide receiver position here at some
point in the future hey Mario Cooper
told me a few weeks back that he's
shooting for 2,000 yards this year if he
gets 2,000 yards which is highly
unlikely but if he has more than 1,500
yards oh he's a guy that the Cowboys
gonna have to use the franchise tag on
in 2020 in order to keep him around and
and for him that big he's making much
more than either Elliott or Prescott
this year so he
and be patient right as opposed to
Elliot who's holding out and Prescott
who seems to want to get something
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports